[Musique]
bonjour ce samedi matin j'ai rendez vous
avec isabelle et jonathan des parents
qui trouvent que leurs enfants passent
beaucoup trop de temps devant leur écran
préférées
[Musique]
une pression effectivement les enfants
ne viennent peut-être paraît sur yon
accès à tous les enfants peuvent rester
chez eux puis voir en vidéo
leurs amis n'ont même pas besoin de
sortir de la maison que tu es comme avec
tes amis
[Musique]
à mon arrivée les enfants jouent au sol
isabelle un truc simple pour les faire
monter on dit cris bastos en jeu y
envoyer un message lu au moins un repas
par jour qui prient ensemble ce qu'on se
parle on demande aux enfants de l'aider
si la tablette il ya cachent souvent
derrière la chaise en général que dès
qu'on a les yeux fermés ou détournés
mais y regardent leurs messages alors
avec les enfants comment gérer ça parce
que c'est compliqué c'est la question
est ce qu'on gère ça avec les enfants
[Musique]
dans la famille d'isabelle on trouve une
bonne douzaine d'écrans rien
d'extraordinaire quand on sait que 90 %
des foyers québécois sont connectés à
internet et que la majorité d'entre eux
possèdent ordinateur télé connectée
consoles de jeux et téléphones
intelligents alors vous avez vos outils
préférés sur les genoux
vous passez beaucoup de temps avec
environ 6 à je pense non ouais un peu
moins ça dépend des jours n'est pas
surtout
honnêtement je suis carrément passer
facilement je suis pas je passe des
personnes qui donnait trop accro je
trouverai d'autres choses à faire gérer
gérer que mes amis je trouvais mai mais
c'est sûr que mon passé je voudrais pas
vraiment les heures de journée et qui
sont réveillés jeudi à la maison
il ya 80% du temps ils sont sourds comme
victor 16 ans et daphné 13 ans ont
chacun leurs tablettes dont ils se
servent à la fois pour les devoirs et
les loisirs qui ont seuls dans leur
chambre tout le temps isabelle je suis
en train d'étudier je peux pas je peux
pas fermer ma tablette alors que c'est
en fait ce pauvre et dressons en train
de de chatter ou de joies des jeux moi
aussi j'ai un peu perdu et pourtant je
me connais beaucoup g22 à doha à la
maison fou comme une génération
sacrifiée on est la première génération
qui avons connu l'arrivée d'internet on
n'a pas d'expérience martin lessard et
chroniqueur techno à l'émission la
sphère aïssi radio-canada première il
observe le monde numérique depuis plus
de vingt ans je les contacter par
facetime
comment tu vis au quotidien si je leur
co internet mais ils se privent de
wikipédia et se prive de sites web ou de
chaîne youtube qu'ils peuvent utiliser
pour leurs travaux si je coupe internet
je coupe aussi leurs liens avec leurs
réseaux d'amis des fois daphné a fait
ses travaux en même temps quatre sur
facetime avec une copine donc ça jase en
même temps qu'elle fait son travail des
vacations mon devoir payer toujours
quelque chose qui se passe piège et
toujours comme concentrer plus sur ce
qu'ils sont mon devoir je commence à je
prends une pause commence à regarder
puis après je vais comme julien plus mon
devoir plaies après je me paie le matin
et plus je me dis j'ai oublié de te vois
plus je le fais rapide mais le truc sans
vie n'est-ce chiasso ont pris regarder
le nom de l'éducation qui a eu juste le
temps qu'on fait l'entrevue de le
regarder
facilement vrai os est un touche
vraiment pas notre fils
la notification c'est une invention du
diable parce que c'est quelque chose qui
arrive qui vient de tête de titiller du
coin de l'oeil ou de la juste d'une son
big derrière ça il ya une éducation
sociale quelqu'un s'intéresse à mon
message quelqu'un me répond en plus de
nous distraire tout le temps les écrans
perturbe le sommeil
le pire c'est quand c'est pour jouer
parce qu'il passe à prendre du temps de
s'endormir pour lire ce pass pire mais
pour jouer bundy victor a pris la bonne
habitude de lire avant de se coucher
mais ce qu'ils ignorent c'est que la
lumière émise par sa tablette perturbe
son sommeil pour en savoir plus je
l'invite au centre d'etudes avancées en
médecine du sommeil de l'hôpital du
sacré coeur
nous avons rendez vous avec l'associé de
recherche véronique d'un autre
grâce à des électrodes elle est capable
d'enregistrer ces zones cérébrales
c'est par cette méthode que les
chercheurs peuvent étudier la qualité du
sommeil c'est la sécrétion de la
mélatonine du post du jus
c'est une hormone que liées au sommeil
qui permette endormir cette hormone la
électrices ans malade ni avec deux
sources de ne surtout à la lumière qui
est riche en lumières bleues il se
trouve que on ne trouvait dans nos yeux
il ya une quinzaine d'années à des
cellules les cellules à mélanopsine
qu'on appelle qui sont elles
particulièrement sensibles à la lumière
bleue lumière qui se trouve donc en très
grande quantité dans nos écrans lumineux
donc je comprendrais que quand on
s'expose à de la lumière et pertinemment
la lumière bleue lyon ville stimuler
notre cerveau on envoyait un signal dvi
à notre cerveau autre fléau
le syndrome du coup textos les
chiropraticiens le voit de plus en plus
car nous passons trop de temps la tête
penchée sur nos cellulaires ici on est
l'image d'un patient réel qui à 17 ans
sur la prise cette image là alors vous
voyez la courbe jones et la courbe
normale du coup et on voit la courbure
du patient alors elle ne suis pas du
tout la normale on a le cou très droit
et c'est trop vers l'avant dans la
portion supérieure
donc ça peut amener des problématiques
autant que de l'arthrose que d'autres
symptômes des motards des migraines des
douleurs au cou des engourdissements
dans les mains on peut même avoir des
problèmes respiratoires
la surutilisation des écrans peut
également provoquer la myopie de plus en
plus jeunes ce trouble de la vision
touche deux fois plus d'enfants qu'il ya
vingt ans une véritable épidémie
cet automne clément rejoindra son frère
et sa soeur à l'école secondaire privée
où il aura sa propre tablette pour ses
études
ce qui inquiète sa maman lui se lever à
5 heures du matin juste pour avoir le
temps de jouer avant d'aller à l'école
donc lui va être surveillé un peu plus
que les autres pensent c'est lui qui
n'avait envoyé un message d'amour là
mais à une heure du matin quand même
alors
quant à nora le petit dernier il est
déjà tombé dans la marmite du numérique
je vois le petit qui a 4 ans aller sur
mon téléphone garder je veux faire ses
jeux ou sur internet façon de
l'ordinateur si c'est sûr c'est plus tu
commences tour plus tu voir des
facilités noah n'a rien d'exceptionnel
il fait partie des quatre milliards
d'humains qui s'informent socialiste et
sa muse grâce à internet
3 2 lundi
ces soucis-là vient de répondre à un
besoin fondamental chez nous c'est que
nous les humains on est curieux de
nature
l'homme entendu sans merci beaucoup aux
renégats c'est ben oui pourquoi pas
l'annoncer